we're going to have a look at this
question that comes under the nature
of proof so read it with me and let's
think about a couple of approaches we
could use
to prove this result prove that a cubed
minus a
is divisible by 6 for all values of a
such that a is an integer okay how do we
go about this
now one of the first things that might
come to your mind when you look at a
question like this is whether
a tool like mathematical induction might
be useful here
now we can use mathematical induction to
prove this result and you could think
all right if i don't need any kind of
you know sophisticated knowledge beyond
extension one
i might as well just go with that right
but there is a reason why in fact a
couple of reasons at least
why using mathematical induction to
prove this particular result
is less than ideal so i'm going to walk
you through what those reasons
are and then i'm going to show you an
alternative path for actually proving
this result that doesn't rely on
induction
at all so let's have a think about how i
would lay this out
if i were to do this by induction what's
the first step when you begin
any proof by mathematical induction and
the answer is you need to
test the base case the first place uh
the first value
where this statement is true now this is
where you run into your first
snag because when you have a think about
okay what am i going to test
what value of a should i choose and the
answer is
well for the set of integers there's no
agreed upon starting point that will
cover all of the numbers that you need
for example
if you start from n equals zero and then
you just start counting up one two three
four five six
you have missed like half of the
integers all of the negative ones right
you could start from some number earlier
on like negative one or negative two or
negative three
but you still run up against this fact
that induction as we have learnt it is a
mono-directional process so it's always
going to start from one value
the base case and then keep on going in
one direction
now this is not an you know impossible
barrier to overcome if you think back to
when we proved
uh de moivre's theorem we could actually
do that by mathematical
induction and i actually showed you know
if you start off by saying
look let's have uh this statement here
and consider it for
zero one and two it becomes uh and so on
and becomes a fairly straightforward use
of some trigonometric identities and
some rearrangement
you can prove this and then you just
need to cover the negative
integers so you need to use some other
trigonometric identities to handle that
you use the result that we just proved
for positive values of
n and then off you go it's fine for the
negative values
too but it's worth keeping in mind that
this is not just going to be if we use
mathematical induction
it's not just going to be a straight
proof we're going to have to handle half
of the cases
so here you can see me choosing you know
1
as my first value and then i'm going to
have to do all that work and consider
the negatives
as well so first snag
sort of addressed i haven't solved it
but i know it's there my second snag
comes after i do the assumption step you
can see i'm just going to
assume that this is true for some
arbitrary value of
a and what i can say is using some of
the notation that we have learned
recently in
the nature of proof there exists some
value of p
which where p is one of the integers
such that k cubed minus k
is six times p so what i'm saying here
is
k cubed minus k is going to be some
multiple of 6
which is analogous equivalent to saying
it's divisible by 6.
and we know the assumption step isn't a
whole lot of work it's the proof step
not for k but for k plus 1 where the
real rubber hits the row
and this is where we hear our second
major snag you can see what happens when
we just say well let's just
see what happens for k plus 1. we go
ahead substitute it in
i'm going to say there exists some value
q which is also an integer
which is going to give me my new
multiple of 6 and then i do
my substitution into the left hand side
and see well what's going to happen here
now those of you who remember
mathematical induction will recall
that what you want to do here is try and
twist and turn this algebraically in
order to make the inductive hypothesis
the assumption
to make it sort of appear and then you
can do a substitution and then hopefully
things fall out in the wash
and you arrive uh if you're starting on
the left hand side you arrive on the
right hand side
now when i have a look at my inductive
hypothesis which is up here
k cubed minus k equals 6 p i can
actually already see
k cubed and minus k in the left-hand
side
of my equation here right uh expression
i should say this is the k
cubed and here is the minus k so i could
just substitute those
for 6p by assumption then there's a bit
of other simplifying as well that will
happen
so let's watch what happens what takes
place when i do that substitution
you can see i've brought this k cubed
minus k out the front i've substituted
for 6q
i noticed my plus and my minus 1 have
canceled with each other leaving me with
this
and then i have uh done this
factorization because i noticed the 3k
can come out the front now at this point
you pause because you think great i i
want to prove
that this is equal to actually that
should be a 6p
and a 6q let's fix that up i've got this
part at the front
this part is divisible by 6. great then
i have to deal with this
what do i do with this set of terms over
here
now the short answer is probably in this
scheme the most efficient way to go
about this
is not very efficient at all i have to
kind of start a whole new proof by
induction
to handle this part of things prove that
it is divisible by six
and then i can do a substitution so i've
got this multiple six
another multiple of six and then
everything will be fine
and it's worth noting sometimes you have
to do that sometimes you have sort of a
babushka doll situation
it feels like you're differentiating by
the chain rule it's like oh not function
of a function it's
mathematical induction of a mathematical
induction
this is the second snag that i was
talking about can work
but certainly doesn't seem elegant right
is there another way
that we can go about this the answer is
yes we're going to have to improve uh
sort of not improve we're going to have
to employ
some deductive logic that we're not used
to using in
the context of number theory but it's
going to be much more elegant
even though it might in the end end up
being sort of a similar amount of
working but i think the the flow of the
logic
will be much clearer so let's rewind
let's go back to
treating this question from the
beginning how can we go about proving
this
without resorting to induction what i'm
going to do first is i'm just going to
take this expression here a cubed minus
a
and i'm going to see if i can gain any
insight from it by manipulating it
algebraically so what i'm going to do is
i'm considering
a cubed minus a now what can i do with
this
the most obvious thing that jumps out at
you is say well i can
factorize this in fact i can factorize
it a couple of times i can first take
out that common factor of a
that leaves me with a squared minus 1
and then you think
fantastic i have differences of squares
here so i've got a
outside of a minus one a
plus one and at this point it's all
factorized and you might think well
what can i do with this what i want you
to notice
is that what you have is a product of
three different numbers but they're not
just three random numbers these numbers
a and a minus one and a plus one
they're actually connected they're
related in that if i put them in this
order
a minus one and then a and then
a plus one what you can see here is
i actually have three consecutive
integers you've got one number here in
the middle
a number one less and a number one more
so i've got
three integers in a row here now this is
important it's so important i'm going to
write it down i'm going to say therefore
a cubed minus a is the product
of three consecutive integers
now at this point uh three
consecutive integers at this point i
need to think
before i make any further you know
algebraic marks on my page
how can i use this property the fact
that a cubed minus a
can be written as the product of three
consecutive integers how can i use this
to construct a proof
here's how it's going to go about i want
to prove that this is divisible by 6
right now
6 itself i can break into two component
pieces because 6 is a composite number
if you were to factorize 6 it would
break into 2
times 3 now what that means is if a
number is divisible by 6
that implies it's also divisible by 2
because it's even
and it's also going to be divisible by 3
it should be a multiple
of 3 as well so therefore if i can prove
this in the opposite direction right
because these
are equivalent statements if you're
divisible by 6
then it it must be true that you're
divisible by 2 and 3 but
if you're divisible by 2 and 3 you must
be divisible by 6.
if i can prove uh this sort of pair of
results then i have proved
the initial result that i set out to uh
to actually prove so that's
that's my uh roadmap through this
question okay if i can prove this
by 2 and divisible by 3 i'm good to go
now if you just think about this and
maybe an example would be instructive
here if you thought of
three consecutive integers any three
consecutive integers like say i don't
know
14 15 16.
what you see here is if you pick any
three consecutive integers
um at least one of them is going to be
even in this case i've got 14 and 16
they're both even right
but if i went along to the next one
let's suppose i scrapped 14 and i
consider the next one
you can see here even though i don't
have 14 anymore
16 is still there so you're always going
to have at least one number that's a a
multiple of two
and because you've got three numbers you
also will always have a number that's a
multiple of
three in this case it's 15. if i were to
scrap 15 and say well let's
put on the next one now 18 is my
multiple
of 3 and if i rewind you can see i had
14 15 16. so this time the multiple
three is the middle number
so if there's always going to be at
least one multiple of two there's always
going to be at least one multiple of
three when you multiply them together
two and three will definitely be one of
your pairs of your factors so therefore
six is also going to be a factor